speaking of hate speech
is a professor at Rutgers University
who has made the news again I remember
seeing something about her earlier but
this is a tenured professor I believe
or at least 10-year track Brittany
Cooper
she's known as Professor krung assistant
professor of women's and gender studies
and Africana studies at Rutgers
University so you can tell she's
definitely the creme de La Creme of the
scholars she
she has some thoughts about white people
I think that white people are committed
to being villains in the aggregate right
the real sort of issue here that you
know I've heard people sort of say it is
one I think that white people viscerally
fear it's not that white people don't
know right what they have done they know
they fear that there is no other way to
be human but the way in which they are
human which is to so you know like you
talk to white people and whenever you
you really want to have a reckoning
about it they say stuff like you know
it's just human nature if y'all had all
of this power you would have done the
same thing right and it's like no that's
what white humans did white human beings
thought there's a world here and we own
it prior to them black and brown people
have been sailing across oceans
interacting with each other for
centuries without total subjugation
domination and colonialism right
it
just as a little historical fact check
here
that that isn't true
they're they're what
you did not have uh black Africans
crossing the Atlantic Ocean to interact
with the Americans that didn't that that
never happened you didn't have Native
Americans crossing the ocean to interact
with Europeans and Africans that that
didn't happen what what she's saying is
white people white people are the
problem they're uniquely bad it isn't
just human nature listen to what she's
saying she's not saying
look this is a fallen world and there
but for the grace of God go I and you
know some people a lot of power can
corrupt people sometimes and no she's
saying it's just it's just white people
white people are bad
black people non-white people in general
are good she goes on about power
I do think that all of us can sort of
agree that a politics that says like
there are superior and inferior human
beings just isn't the way to go and
that's the thing that white people don't
trust us to do because they are so
corrupt you know their thinking is so
morally and spiritually bankrupt about
power that they can't let you know they
fear viscerally existentially letting go
of power because they cannot imagine
that there's another way to be it is
either that you dominate or you are
dominated and isn't it sad that that is
spiritually who they are and that they
can't imagine a sort of more expansive
notion of the world the thing I want to
say to you is we got to take these
[ __ ] out but I know but like we
can't say that right we can't say like I
don't believe in a project of violence I
truly don't because I think in the end
that our souls suffer from that
but you did just say that you you just
said you you accused white people of uh
viewing power dynamics as a relation of
the dominant to the dominated and how
people have to hold on the white people
believe you have to hold on to power
you're not willing to let it go
because these white people believe if
you let it go you know then the people
you give the power to are just going to
want to take you out and also I want to
take these mother refers out so she does
exact and she says I'm not I can't say
that but you did just say that
and that is obviously
what you believe
that what this professor professor crunk
Brittany Cooper is expressing is a view
of power dynamics
that says we need to take power from
white people and then we need to punish
the white people why
there were people out here making worlds
Africans and Indigenous people being
brilliant and you know libraries and
inventions and you know vibrant Notions
of humanity and cross-cultural exchange
long before white people showed up being
raggedy and violent and terrible and
trying to take everything from everybody
so there there was this
history of
The cross-cultural Exchange and
inventions and all this great stuff
before those awful raggedy white people
showed up and and destroyed everything
just as a matter of historical record
there was not there was not Not only was
there not a long history of an invention
in exchange and trade and all in all of
these places
there wasn't even the invention of the
wheel the invention of the wheel did not
occur in the Americas or in Africa they
didn't get the wheel until
exploration until so you might say as
often the the sort of liberals will say
the anti-colonialism anti-western
Liberals will say they'll say well all
these societies were living in this
wonderful Utopia before the damn white
man got there and ruined everything and
it was all basically just Avatar and the
Disney version of Pocahontas so if
you're going to make that claim then you
you actually would want to say yeah
there weren't a lot of inventions there
wasn't a ton of Technology you would
make the liberal claim that it's
actually all of that invention and
consumption and capitalism that destroys
societies you would say no no you keep
your stupid inventions Europeans we hate
we were doing just fine without you
that would be one version of the
argument or the other version of the
argument they could make is no we had
this thriving wonderful Society with all
of these inventions and all of this
technological progress and then you
terrible white people came in and and
screwed it all up but then if you make
that argument then you can't attack
modern capitalism and modern technology
in modern industry as very often that
the people who make these these kind of
arguments do and here Professor Cooper
is trying to make both simultaneously
and it doesn't work it does not hold up
so what is the upshot of all of this I
mean she's she's not making very good
arguments what is the end game here
white folks are not infinite and eternal
right they ain't gonna go on for
infinity and infinity and that's super
important to remember that White's
colonialism and imperialism has a
beginning and in my way of thinking
about the world that means it has an end
and so part of what we are trying to do
is to imagine what it what are the steps
that we must take to get to the other
side of this very inconvenient you know
epaco Interruption of like black and
Indigenous world making I mean does that
give people Comfort on a day to day when
you like just having to deal with white
folks and the track you know the
travesties that they create in the sense
that they want to destroy the planet nah
nah nah of course not but but the end
game is the end of white people and
that's what we all need to hope for and
wait for and pray for is that the white
people will just disappear
genocide is what this woman is calling
for why is this clip going around right
now
this clip is not from two days ago this
clip is from last year I believe why is
it making the rounds now
it's more important that it's making the
rounds now than that it made the rounds
a year ago because it's been out there
before and this woman
if she were A different race making
comments about people of another race
would be not only fired from her job of
course she would she would be banned
from everywhere she would be she would
be kicked off of all social media she
would probably be kicked out of her
neighborhood she would probably be
debanked okay she would be removed from
society and she is not
the the reason it matters that that we
see these kinds of videos and see this
kind of commentary is to show you that
very point about hierarchy and hypocrisy
okay the these the the liberal media
want to whip us up into a frenzy about
anything that you possibly could see on
the right meanwhile the things that they
say the things that they do are are so
so much more egregious and and it's why
I can't get worked up it's why I just I
simply to get right back to the first
story of the show I cannot get worked up
about the things Trump does Trump is a
freaking choir boy compared to the libs
the stuff that Trump says that the
tweets the Mean Tweets the things about
people's faces the tax issue that he had
so he's got this minor tax fine I just
it's nothing compared to these people
the fact that I don't know there was
some story about
the Republicans pressuring someone to do
I don't even know remember what was the
first impeachment thing that they tried
it does it doesn't even matter when you
look at the corruption of of the
Democrats when you look at the way that
the Democrats
and potentially the government now it
seems were pressuring social media to
rig their elections for it's just I
don't care because whenever we cover
these stories
the Democrats will say and the libs and
the people on social media Michael you
can't you can't suggest there was a
problem with the election you can't you
can't you have to go out you've got to
constantly attack Republicans whenever
they say anything that is not totally
approved by Twitter and Facebook I don't
I don't want to hear it listen to the
violence the absolutely vile
the rhetoric coming out of this woman's
mouth
the fact that no one has cared it's been
out there for a year that that tells you
more than anything that she or any
Republican has to say now you know it's
woke Wednesday
we have a great great presentation today
to educate all of us to open up our
minds
from Love Don't Judge okay I'm gonna I
want you to have your Consciousness
elevated with me we're going to reserve
our judgment we're going to see how long
we can reserve our judgment while
watching this the rest of the show
continues now if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]